Genies von Kara haben die Rocker entlassen. Wurdest du
jemals während der Dreharbeiten verletzt,
weil du deine Stunts alleine machst,
und was war die schlimmste Art von
Verletzung, die du immer
verletzt hast?
diese
Dinge passieren Fehler und du versuchst zu
versuchen und zu sehen, dass du versuchst,
die Gefahren so gut wie möglich zu eliminieren, aber es wird
immer etwas schief gehen, es gibt
immer eine Art Chaos, so eine Art
Mangel an Brockmore, und du weißt, ob es
nie einen gegeben hat  ein gebrochenes Bein oder ein gebrochener Arm,
aber Sie wissen, dass Sie dazu neigen,
die Gelenke zu belasten, da die Schulter ein
sehr leicht zu verletzendes Gelenk
ist  Weißt du, deine Finger werden nach hinten gebogen
und gequetscht, aber du weißt, dass ein gebrochenes Glied
etwas ist, wonach
du nicht suchst. Okay,
natürlich nicht
explosiv. Vor Jahren gab es so
viele Stars wie Stallone Sc  Hwarzenegger
oder Willis, was denkst du jetzt, es ist
nur Jason, wo sind die jungen
Actionstars der heutigen Zeit,
sie tragen Strumpfhosen und einen Umhang
, das tun sie, du siehst nicht aus
wie der klassische Action-Action-Mann. Ich
glaube, wir haben unsere gefragt  Community, sie sind
nur Jason Stefan, natürlich weißt du, dass
ich gerne Actionfilme mache
Du weißt, sie sind aufregend,
sie sind die, sie haben etwas, von dem
du weißt, dass ich es liebe, du weißt, ich mag eine
wirklich gute Geschichte, wie eine wahre Geschichte, wie
Dramen, wie eine Komödie, so etwas wie
viele Dinge, aber meine Leidenschaft sind
Actionfilme  Ich wollte schon immer in ihnen sein
und es passiert einfach so, dass ich
die Filme mache, die ich machen möchte. Louis, einer
ist derjenige, den Suki markiert hat. Wer ist Ihr
schauspielerisches Vorbild
?  Ich erinnere mich immer noch an Leute
von von Ihnen, die Sie von gestern kennen  und ich
Steve McQueen und Paul Newman Clint
Eastwood, du kennst Charles Bronson, das
sind die Leute, die ich mag, die
meine Eltern früher beobachtet haben, und das sind die
Leute, mit denen ich aufgewachsen bin, also weißt du,
dass ich diese Leute immer so betrachte, wie
sie  Es sind die Leute, die mich
mehr in Filmen beeinflusst haben als alles andere,
aber es gibt auch eine
andere Generation wie Sylvester
Stallone und all diese warzenkichernden
Leute mit ihnen, besonders
eine, die den größten Einfluss
für mich haben möchte  Sagen wir mal, Bruce Lee war für
mich das Nonplusultra von dem, was ich Actionfilme nenne.
Ich dachte nur, er hätte einen körperlichen
Ausdruck, den niemand sonst
annähernd erreichen konnte, um sich bei Ihnen zu bedanken